let's talk about the best foods that can
help clean out your arteries
we're talking about a problem that
involves the inside
of the layer of your arteries it's
called the endothelial
layer and if there's a dysfunction with
this layer
you get inflammation and you also get
scar tissue fibrosis you also have
calcium buildup and cholesterol buildup
and you can also have a clot which is a
little bit different and one of the
absolute best tests to figure out
what's going on on the inside of your
arteries is this right over here it's
the coronary
artery calcification test or scan
get it from your doctor it's pretty
quick it's not that expensive
it's way more valuable than a
cholesterol test
because it's measuring the amount of
calcium buildup in your arteries which
is one of the best predictors or
mortality
from all deaths so it's a really
important test it should be zero but
sometimes it could be
100 200 500 700 even a thousand or more
the key is if you find that it's very
high you want to apply what i'm going to
show you
and then retest it every several months
and make sure it's going down all right
starting from number one
you want to make sure that your insulin
is normal
okay you don't want it too high and you
do that by dropping your carbs so
anything low carb
would be very very therapeutic to your
arteries so you want to do a low-carb
diet
ketogenic diet and you want to do
fasting okay very very important
because that will lower insulin insulin
will cause
inflammation in the inside of the
arteries and the artery will become
thickened and you may even develop a
clot
there'll be inflammation and something
called
age advanced glycated
end products that's a situation that
occurs
where the inside of your artery the
proteins become
unusable they're damaged and you get
this
from consuming too many carbs and you
can also get it from
consuming like too many omega-6 oils
which i'll mention a little bit
so this would be number one this is
probably
the absolute most important thing you
must handle this
or these won't really work number two
you want to consume foods high in
vitamin k2
like nato which is a fermented soybean
or liver could be beef liver chicken
liver
eggs definitely the yolk grass-fed
butter
grass-fed beef sauerkraut maybe a little
bit of
hard or soft cheese that has vitamin k2
the vitamin k2
is all about keeping the calcium out of
the arteries
all right number three this is not a
food but
it's a very powerful antioxidant
tocatrinos is different than tocopherols
this is the vitamin e complex
tocotrinols are 50 times stronger than
tocopherols
now if you're consuming green leafy
vegetables you're going to get
a good amount of vitamin e so you can
also do that but if you actually have
damage inside your arteries
tocotrinols would be something i would
highly recommend because
they're very very powerful they can stop
the fibrosis or scar tissue from getting
any worse
and it gets rid of free radical damage
all right number four decreasing omega-6
fatty acids so you need to get rid of
the soy oils the corn oil
the canola the cotton seed out of your
diet
and replace that with omega-3 fatty
acids
fatty fish salmon cod liver oil
you can do walnuts which has a precursor
to omega-3
and also make sure that if you're doing
meats they're grass-fed
it has higher amounts of omega-3 fatty
acids
number five to decrease the stiffness of
the arteries
which can then lead to high blood
pressure you want to have enough
potassium in the diet
potassium keeps the arteries
nice and soft the problem is most people
don't consume enough
salad or vegetable to be able to have
enough potassium and they're usually low
an average american has about one and a
half cups of vegetable per day when in
fact they need at least
seven or more and so that will give you
the potassium to really help
your blood pressure you can also get it
in a good electrolyte powder
now the other thing is vitamin d vitamin
d
is very very important in keeping your
blood pressure
low it supports this dysfunction
in a very big way it can help your
arteries from a lot of different angles
so vitamin d it's almost impossible to
get it from food
you can get it from fatty fish and cod
liver oil but the best
way is through the sun or supplement
here's the thing you need about at least
10
000 ius of vitamin d
or even more to drop blood pressure but
you'll actually see that blood pressure
will come down when you take it so the
combination of potassium vitamin d is
very very
powerful in keeping the arteries from
being too stiff
now there's another um good remedy for
high blood pressure pomegranate okay you
can get it as a supplement or consume
the seeds in your salad
it has great properties to lower blood
pressure
so there you have it some foods to focus
on to keep your arteries clean
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today